I'm I'm better at leading the idea of
the movement that we're trying to get
behind and being able to like message
that and communicate that well
externally and to a degree internally
and so I think it was really becoming
the person who could cast that Vision
which sounds really lame and I think
that's where a lot of the work comes in
is like what do I believe to be true and
what do I want to make true in the world
and so I think that's what we tried to
build with this company compared to some
of the other companies that we built in
the past which you know transparently
the first companies we have the mission
was like don't be broke so